much of the open ocean is referred to as
a biological desert the vast majority of
the sea is hundreds or thousands of
kilometers from land and is mostly empty
water poor in nutrients and therefore
containing little diversity in life
forms the parts of the sea we know and
love the coral reefs full of schools of
colorful fish or the channels between
islands where dolphins and whales and
sea turtles all spend time make up just
a tiny percentage of the ocean
for a long time the only thing we were
certain populated the open ocean in huge
numbers was something of our own making
plastic sometimes these garbage debris
fields are so concentrated that they get
their own names like the Great Pacific
Garbage Patch garbage vortexes like this
are a nasty Testament to the state of
our modern world and we can't help but
think of them with sadness and disgust
and a desire for somebody to scoop it
all up
but the way we think about Ocean garbage
patches may actually be kind of wrong I
know when I first heard about the Great
Pacific Garbage Patch I pictured a dense
singular floating barge of trash but
really the metric F load of trash that's
out there is more like a smattering of
individual garbage pieces over a large
area and much to everyone's surprise
scientists have discovered that Ocean
garbage patches are not at all devoid of
life it turns out that an entire class
of organisms lives their entire lives
among the trash and in great numbers
and these creatures look nothing like
almost any other animal forget fins and
Tails and glittering scales these
jellyfish snails Barnacles hydrazoans
and nudibranchs belong to a class of
their own with fantastic and beautiful
adaptations to their environment these
floating organisms live on the surface
of the water and go wherever the wind
and ocean currents take them they come
in dazzling shades of blue and purple
helping them blend into the surface of
the water and each has its own special
trick for surviving their unique
environment an environment which is a
thin sliver of water and air that's only
about one meter in thickness all of
these organisms live right alongside the
plastic collected in gyres by the very
same forces that sweep our trash into
certain parts of the ocean which means
whenever we try to collect all that
trash we're also in advertently sweeping
away and killing hundreds or even
thousands of unique organisms
so what are we supposed to do is there a
way to clean up the ocean without
killing all of these incredible life
forms or do we simply just leave all
that trash how important to the health
of the overall ocean are these colorful
floating creatures and what other
Mysteries might they still hold
even under the calmest conditions oceans
are never completely still ocean gyres
are a perfect example of this there are
five major gyres found across the planet
in the North and South Pacific North and
South Atlantic and in the Indian Ocean
they're created by the spinning rotation
of the planet the blowing wind and the
placement of land masses and there are
plenty of smaller gyres all over the
oceans too the sargasso Sea is located
in the Atlantic but has its own
ecosystem and own boundaries defined by
winds and currents it's also filled with
sargassum an algae that experiences its
entire life on the ocean surface rather
than needing to reproduce attached to
the sea floor that algae is a hugely
important habitat for numerous species
from sea turtles to eels but the largest
gyre of all is the North Pacific
subtropical gyre and it couldn't be more
different from the sargasso sea for a
long time it was thought to be largely
devoid of life being so far from the
coastline
but in the 1950s a Soviet research
vessel crisscrossed the Pacific taking
samples along the way and discovered
something astonishing the surface of the
ocean was filled with life creatures
that floated and bobbed letting the wind
and waves take them everywhere
these organisms were named newston a
word that plays on Plankton combined
with the Greek nustos for swimming some
new Sonic life forms only come to the
surface for certain stages of their life
cycle like fish larvae but obligate
newston spend their whole lives in the
thin space between sea and sky they're
moved by the same forces that shape the
ocean gyres but since the 1950s there's
also been a new element added to the mix
plastic
annual plastic production is close to
400 million metric tons and each year
several million tons of that plastic
enters the ocean
a lot of that trash gets caught around
the coastlines or in rivers but the
pieces that do get swept out to the open
ocean are usually buoyant and become
subject to the same forces that move the
new Sonic creatures around which means
that where there are these organisms
there's probably also trash yet trying
to study these life forms and figuring
out just how much plastic has made it
into the gyre is extremely difficult
logistically the Pacific Ocean is
enormous and boats have to travel slowly
to collect samples there's just a lot we
don't know yet
what we do know is that these life forms
are incredibly strange and unique
[Music]
one of the most iconic members of the
newston family is the siphonophore
Visalia fisalis more commonly known as
the Portuguese man of war they're
Infamous for their incredibly painful
sting which in rare cases can cause
cardiac arrest
though it may appear similar to a
jellyfish the Mana War is actually a
colonial hydrazone while it looks like a
single organism it's made up of
individuals who serve specific purposes
and work together as a collective unit
for Visalia those main units are the new
metaphor an air sac filled with oxygen
and carbon dioxide that acts as a sail
the tentacle polyp used to sting and
capture prey the feeding polyp that
digests food and the reproductive
structure and although it has to rely on
the motion of wind and water to
transport it from place to place the
Portuguese man of war is still a
formidable Hunter its stinging tentacles
can extend multiple meters below the sea
and it feasts on fish that swim into
those tentacles and get stung to death
but just because it has some good
strategies for catching mobile prey
doesn't mean fisalia is safe from other
predators in fact it's the favored food
of a species so bizarre it barely looks
real a nudie Brink known as the blue sea
dragon
Glaucus atlanticus and its relatives
might look like harmless and dazzling
little sea slugs but they're actually
armed with an incredible weapon Stingers
that they steal from the Portuguese man
of war
Rebecca Helm an environmental scientist
who specializes in new Sonic life forms
has had first-hand experience with blue
sea dragons and says they need to be
handled with care
in General on a large scale they'll eat
a tentacle and within the tentacle there
are special cells that are shaped like
eggs that contain the hypodermic needle
that the Manowar uses to deliver Venom
so when they eat a tentacle they have to
somehow
right like dig out these stinging cells
like digging out a cherry pit and then
in their gut their branches all the way
up to the surface of their skin and so
each little cell gets redirected in
their digestive tract up to their skin
unfired still somehow somehow and we
really have no idea
because you can fire those tentacles
with the briefest touch and somehow
they're able to move them through their
digestive tract up to the surface of
their skin through these really cool
canals
um unfired just waiting there for
someone usually you know a scientist or
a curious person to touch them and then
that's it but the blue sea dragon
doesn't have any method of moving itself
either its ability to float comes from
the bubble of air that it swallows and
holds in its stomach instead of seeking
out prey it has to wait for the ocean
currents to bring it in direct contact
with the hydrazone and then it employs
another trick they're called Serrata but
they look like hands and they're coming
off the side of their body and they
actually use them like little hands to
grab things and it's so neat to see them
you know interact with their environment
and try to catch food and and they truly
can't swim they have no control over
where they go and what they do so they
just kind of relax and sit inside done
and when something bumps into them it's
like they're so fast their tail is
prehensile so they can wrap onto things
with their tail and sort of hold on to
multiple things at once and just kind of
eat them one at a time
they're really really cool but the blue
sea dragon isn't the only creature that
eats Portuguese Mana Warriors
so do the Violet snails janthina
janthina which also can't swim these
snails have to create bubble wraps from
their own mucus just to stay afloat and
must be extremely careful when they're
consuming prey if the Violet snails eat
too much of their prey and don't have a
stable raft of bubbles both prey and
Predator will sink
the ability to stay afloat and be
carried by wind and waves is critical
for these strange organisms just as the
Portuguese man of war relies on its new
metaphor to stay on the ocean's surface
a hydrazone called vallello vallella aka
the by the wind sailor has a dorsal fin
protruding from its body to help it
catch the breeze
but sometimes that little sail can
backfire these organisms are regularly
seen on coastlines around the world
after Mass stranding events
when the wind switches to blowing
towards the shore hundreds and even
thousands of these cnidarians can end up
on the beach and the problem might be
getting worse for them as water
temperature warms even in Winter
dangerous as plastic is for many marine
species you know at the end of the day
the biggest threat to marine life no
matter where you go in the ocean is our
changing climate and the
unpredictability of that and organisms
that live at the surface they're right
there they are the front line for the
ocean everything that happens in the
ocean has to go through the surface of
the ocean and so temperature changes
changes in weather patterns they're
going to experience it before any other
creatures in the sea
[Music]
and the harm of these man-made problems
can be strange and unpredictable for
example floating plastic doesn't just
enter their environment and make a mess
sometimes it also brings unexpected
visitors historically a very small
number of organisms could travel large
distances over the oceans on Driftwood
colonizing new islands or even
continents but it was rare because
Driftwood decays pretty rapidly
but today plastic presents an optimal
floating surface and organisms that were
previously limited to shorelines are now
traveling out to the open ocean and
doing well enough that they can
reproduce and establish permanent
colonies floating out at Sea one major
example of this was when the massive
tsunami that hit Eastern Japan in 2011
resulted in 4.5 million tons of debris
getting washed out to sea almost
instantly by 2017 more than a hundred
thousand pieces of debris from that
tsunami had landed in North America and
381 Japanese Coastal species came with
it still alive these were mainly little
invertebrates things like muscles
arthropods cnidarians and bryozoans so
it's not like Japanese macaques were
riding the plastic trash all the way
from their home to the Hawaiian Islands
but the fact that some of these
organisms managed to survive a very long
trip over open ocean and in some cases
went through a reproductive cycle in an
environment far different from their own
suggests that they may be able to
establish new populations at sea and
that could have unexpected consequences
are they invasive species that will hurt
the newston will they reshape the food
webs in unexpected ways will they help
clean up the plastic by digesting it
scientists just don't know it's the same
with new Sonic life forms says Dr Helm
so there are some species that seem to
do better in the presence of plastic and
for a long time this really confused me
I I knew why they were laying their eggs
on plastic and they needed something
hard to lay their eggs on and plastic
just happened to be it but I couldn't
figure out if this was a new thing and
they were having this like amazing boom
or if this was a comeback and they were
laying their eggs on something else
but an amazing paper came out a couple
years ago that showed the amount of
natural debris things like large pieces
of wood that is entering the ocean is is
a fraction of what it used to be I mean
it may be down by over 99
so they're using these plastic perhaps
in part because there's no longer much
wood out there so it's hard to know if
these animals are negatively impacted by
Plastics if Plastics may be a an
imperfect and
really kind of
sad substitute for something that used
to be there or if they're sort of
adjusting to something new
or if if Plastics may be harmful in some
ways and
we just don't know
so this brings up the obvious question
should we clean it up or not
this is hard to answer in part because
we don't even know how much garbage is
really out there
it's estimated that by 2050 somewhere
between 155 and 265 million metric tons
of garbage will have entered the ocean
but at this point in time scientists
have only ever found hundreds of
thousands of metric tons in the ocean
that amount accounts for less than one
percent of all the plastic ever thought
to have entered the ocean so where is
the 99 of the missing plastic
scientists believe much of it gets
degraded into microplastics which get
mixed into the sea floor or make their
way into the bodies of ocean organisms
other trash sinks to the deepest parts
of the sea scientists know that the
largest concentrations of garbage are
found in gyres but even these
concentrations are nothing like what
most people picture the gyres cover a
huge area and the trash is very
dispersed says Dr helm it's not this
floating patch of trash that you can see
from space nothing like that at all in
fact if you were on a boat looking out
at the garbage patch it looks like
beautiful pristine ocean it's only when
you look more closely that you realize
something's a little bit unusual about
this particular spot so it's not a
singular dense barge of trash but what
is out there can still cause great harm
to ocean life one of the biggest
problems are lost or discarded fishing
gear called ghost Nets that continue to
do what they do best trap and Tangle
Wildlife like sharks whales and turtles
that may be passing through there's also
a risk that the degrading plastic will
release chemicals into the water and
hurt the animals
but any effort to clean up the plastic
with huge scooping Nets will also
endanger new Sonic life because
researchers have found that the highest
density of animals is positively
correlated with the highest density of
plastic debris and if new Sonic species
are killed in large numbers it could
have an impact on the turtle's fish
seabirds and other animals that eat them
plus plastic might even be helping some
species that lay their eggs on the
plastic
so if scooping the plastic out of the
ocean is a risk to sea creatures what do
we do instead
so I have some colleagues that think we
should just leave it because it's
already in the environment and they have
a good point that when you throw
something away you kind of give up
ownership of it right I mean that's the
whole point and if there are other
creatures living on it which is true for
almost all plastic in the ocean there's
usually something that's turned it into
a home
um you know who are you to go in and
take it back out I I tend to see things
uh as a little bit more
um
more about getting the most dangerous
forms of plastic out in the safest
possible way so I'm a big fan of efforts
to clean up large plastic debris things
like fishing gear that's been lost which
makes up the vast majority of plastic in
the North Pacific Garbage Patch by
weight so these huge fishing nets I mean
they can wait over a ton and they are
designed to catch and kill marine life
and they're designed to stay in the
ocean for long periods of time without
degrading and so they're really
dangerous to a lot of animals in the
ecosystem and they're actually really
effective ways to remove ghost gear that
don't involve yet more Nets
some organizations will give GPS
trackers to Sailors so that they can tag
large pieces of debris when they come
across them and then all those tagged
bits of trash can be collected later
another possibility could be using
certain species of bacteria that
actually eat and digest plastic in fact
those bacteria might be one explanation
for all the missing plastic in the ocean
still we probably shouldn't flood the
open ocean with tons of new bacteria in
hopes that they'll take care of our
garbage we need to find some way to get
all that trash out but we have to take
into consideration which organisms we
might be hurting when we do so
it's commendable what initiatives like
the ocean cleanup project are trying to
do using huge Nets to scoop out tons of
plastic from the garbage patch and they
say they're aware of the potential harm
to ocean life and that they have adapted
their design of its plastic catcher to
allow species to swim away but that's
just the problem many newston can't swim
away and they've started scooping the
plastic before Studies have shown that
there is no impact on the newston many
scientists simply wish for them to slow
down and wait for more data to guide any
massive cleanup effort the ocean
cleanup's other projects like the river
interceptors are likely to be much more
important in the future of the ocean
anyway preventing much of the trash from
flowing out of the most polluting rivers
in the first place
before the development of plastics
newston might have been one of the types
of life that were least impacted by
human activity because they're just so
remote that's not the case anymore and
we still don't know how fragile their
habitats are the solutions aren't as
easy as just collecting the trash but
maybe by studying the creatures who live
amongst it we'll better understand how
to help them and clean up our mess at
the same time
our relationship with the ocean is an
endlessly complicated one and while
nudie Brinks may never be able to take
revenge on us for messing with their
habitat some of their ocean Brethren
already are as we talked about in our
last video orcas seem to be letting us
know that they are tired of our nonsense
by ripping boats apart in the North
Atlantic it feels like our relationship
with these creatures and perhaps all
ocean creatures is reaching a crisis
point but it doesn't have to be this way
and it certainly wasn't always this way
and in fact at one point in history in
one specific Place orcas and humans
weren't at odds with each other but
rather were allies friends and even
business partners the orcas of Eden
worked alongside humans for decades to
hunt Baleen whales off the coast of
Australia in the most incredible example
ever recorded of orca human cooperation
the combined forces of the world's top
two apex predators was insurmountable
and dozens of the world's biggest
animals were taken down every year what
could compel two apex predators from
totally different environments to work
together to achieve a common goal how do
they communicate and how did they each
keep up their end of the deal this story
of the orcas of Eden is so incredible
that I made another full-length video
about it that you can watch now on
nebula here's a quick preview
once the bloody hunt was complete the
men would leave the carcass anchored in
place and let the orcas have the first
go the orcas ate the lips and tongue of
the Baleen whales then the humans
returned to harvest the rest of the Body
for its oil
this exchange was known as the law of
the tongue and it continued for decades
through multiple generations of the
Davidson family among the most famous
and recognizable of the Orca Partners
was a large male known as old Tom his
help was so invaluable that at one point
when George Davidson was knocked out of
a boat during a hunt Tom circled him in
the water protecting him from sharks
until he was retrieved by the other
humans
but sadly the partnership was doomed to
meet an untimely end
nebula is a streaming platform that we
built for exactly this reason to explore
topics more deeply sometimes in new
formats and sometimes within subject
areas that don't exactly fit our main
YouTube channel this video about the
orcas of Eden mixes history with science
but it's a topic I simply could not
resist making a video about nebula
allows me to take risks like this and
experiment more whether it's this
historical Orca video or the nebula
original series I made called becoming
human about the incredible story of how
we came to understand human evolution
nebula is a place for all of its
creators to make experimental and new
content like Joe Scott's Mysteries of
the human body which takes you through
some of the most baffling diseases and
epidemics from history or Wendover
Productions extremities which shows you
why and how people live in Earth's most
isolated and extreme settlements nebula
has even produced a feature-length film
called night of the coconut and a genre
bending award-winning play called the
prince which you can watch in its
entirety on nebula you can also watch
our next video now on nebula about the
biggest tornadoes in history two weeks
earlier than you can see it on YouTube
and now if you sign up with the link
below subscribers also get access to
classes you can watch dozens of in-depth
classes of creators teaching you how to
create so if you sign up using the link
below you can support this channel
directly and get both nebula and nebula
classes for 40 off the annual plan for
just thirty dollars for the entire year
foreign